welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the mandalorian is back on
disney plus returning to tatooine to
take down some great dragons and true
spoiler warning
resurrect one boba fett to wear more sin
in the flesh
after reacting to the episode with tommy
on wikileaks i have now
combed through this episode and found a
ton of hidden star wars easter eggs
folks boba pett is actually hiding in
plain sight
way earlier in this episode not just
talk about the armor he's there i'm
gonna find him for you i'm gonna break
it all down here we go okay mando and
baby yoda pass
pairs of glowing red eyes from the
hounds in the shadows but baby otis too
busy looking at the graffiti there is
some white arbesch that looks like it
translates to the word alderaan
maybe a memorial for the empire's war
crime there's some more text down the
center that looks like no
more for the backwards in the words you
will learn
to the right of that killer there also
appear to be depictions of a snow
trooper helmet kind of looks like
a protocol droid that looks like c-3po
but they all kind of look the same there
might be chewbacca there and then that
could be wado on the door of the club
some people are also seeing grievous in
there interestingly one of them looks
like the wills those are the legendary
force beings that taught many jedi how
to come back as force ghosts
so gore koresh here is an abyssian voice
by john leguizamo they watched some
gomorians in a fighting ring those are
the race of jabba the hud's guards in
return of the jedi notice how their
battle axes emit this blue glow
this could be based on knights of the
old republic game in which the taurus
arenas used a similar shielding tech to
reduce lethality mando has to take down
koresh's guards with his
whistling birds and his vibro blade they
return from season one the last guy he
takes out is a zabrak
the same race as maul i just love how
mando's best scar
armor is itself an offensive weapon like
the first guy punches him nearly breaks
his own fist
then when he does that that knocks
amanda's helmet into the twilight
it's like all man has to do is just
stand there while other people punch him
into each other
but before i continue i want to thank
bessie shoes for sponsoring this video
see bessie makes these knit sneakers
that are 100 waterproof and weatherproof
they're super breathable too so they
don't let any liquid in but they do let
the air move
out they also have an antimicrobial
insole to keep your footsies from
getting funkier than a mon calamari
sauna hey that's kind of me naman
calamari i'm sure they smell fine
bessie's shoes are super stretchy just
look at them they fit like a
sock and they only weigh 175 grams
they're also made with this cool dynamex
material that keeps your feet warm in
cold weather
but also helps heat escape during the
steamy months like as we head into these
snowy and rainy months depending on
where you live it's really really great
to have besties for running errands
around town and keeping my feet dry and
warm and comfy even when i'm trying to
do too many things at once while i'm
skipping through people's yards
skipping through their grass swallow
them drink them oh
no i spilled water all over my feetsy
wheatsies but my oinky oinkies are blown
dry
like the dunesy thanks bessie
get 25 bucks off your own pair of messy
shoes when you use my link in the
video's description click that link for
25
off these cool weatherproof knit
sneakers thanks bessie when he catches
crash she says
i swear it by the gatra we could be
referencing the droid gotra which is a
group of battle droids and coruscant
during the clone wars who supported
droid rights
droid emancipation kind of a weird thing
for koresh to swear to but it is worth
noting along with mando's new post ig-11
softened attitude toward droids called
out by pelimoto oh
so he likes droids now will you hurt him
give it a one silver
kelly's astromech droid is r5 notice
that burn mark
this is the same r5 with the busted
motivator that luke and oklahoman almost
bought before r2d2 in a new hope
pele also says interestingly you know if
this thing ever
divides or buds i will gladly pay for
the offspring
now the line gets buried by the gag but
i think it's a subtle foreshadowing
hinting at baby yoda's reproductive
cycle that we might learn about his
biological origin
this season okay we see a great map of
tatooine i love maps
we see mos eisley moses and the new most
pogo
not on the map recalling the way kamino
wasn't on the star maps of the jedi
archives but it was nonetheless there
screw you got something new and camino
is another location we might be
revisiting with it being the birthplace
of boba fett
and connected to dr pershing and his
camino patch when he studied baby oda
last season
mando treks out of the town but on the
way he meets with a few tuscan raiders
remember this dude sitting away from the
campfire on the far left
judging mando apprehensively i have a
theory about him also in his dune c is a
bantha skeleton recalling the great
dragon skeleton in a new hope apparently
still in tunisian desert just a little
nod showing us that we're about to see a
living version of the beast 2 skeleton
we last saw like this
amanda's arrival in the town definitely
evokes some spaghetti western imagery
you can get some great side eye with the
locals as we hear
libby gordon's acoustic guitar playing
underneath one of these villagers is a
cameo by
sam whitmore amazing voice actor behind
maul and clone wars and rebels
that's how marshall is cobb bath timothy
oliphant
we quake two snorts of spashka he wears
boba fett's distinctive armor a
backstory originally from chuck wendig's
aftermath books
this weekway bartender is played by w
earl brown
from deadwood making this a kind of
deadwood reunion between him and olivan
you'll remember spotska as the blue
liquor that mando drank with carrot dune
last season and settle down with that
beautiful young widow
and raise your kids sitting here sipping
spotska it's a bit weird when he calls a
bartender by his race as opposed to a
name
the two of them clearly had some kind of
friendship in the past though we
shouldn't feel too bad this guy he is
the ugliest guy in the room who has a
lot of opinions about sand people
they're
monsters they nailed the attention to
detail on this boba fett armor
from the bullet dent on the head there's
a little metal patch on the jet pack
probably to fix where han solo bonked it
you'll also notice the armor looks
corroded
suggesting the sarlacc stomach acid
probably did a number on it now notice
the sound design of the crate dragon
roar
i love it they use the synthy tone from
the original dragon roar
that ben kenobi did to scare up the
tuscan raiders in the first film
[Music]
before george lucas's team re-edited it
in later editions not as good in my
opinion
[Applause]
now cobb's speeder bike is a repurposed
pod racer engine
similar to how rey used one of these in
jakku in the force awakens
cobb's looks a lot like anakin
skywalker's pod racer engine it does
have the yellow flaps though this one is
red i don't remember there being any red
on anakin's
cobb recounts the night of the second
death star exploding after the battle of
endor and return of the jedi the hollow
projection has this ring of auravesh
text around it if you were to flip that
translate it it reads
little does luke know that the galactic
empire has secretly begun construction
on a new armored space station even more
powerful than the first death star
the word for word text from the opening
crawl of return of the jedi that's a fun
easter egg cobb talked about how he
grabbed a camtono containing silica's
crystals
this is the same kind of container that
werner herzog kept the best guard in
last season it's the famous ice cream
maker prop carried by wilrow hood on
cloud city and empire the tuscan raider
hounds they meet are massives we saw
these in attack of the clones but mando
is a friend of these folks he speaks
tuscan uses their hand signals this is
also pretty similar to the knights of
the old republic where you have to team
up with tuscan raiders and you actually
use a similar tactic to take down a
crate dragon
you have to lure it out over buried
explosives the tuscan raiders march back
into town on banthas in a straight line
a little nod to obi-wan kenobi's
description in a new hope
sand people always ride single file to
hide their numbers
now the great dragon lives in an
abandoned sirloc pit there's no such
thing as an abandoned store like pit
there is if you eat the sarlacc this
might explain how boba fett was able to
survive the sarlacc the krait dragon
spews flesh-melting acid
that could have dissolved the sarlacc
flesh but might not have been strong
enough to melt the mandalorian armor
which might have freed boba
though canonically boba's armor is
durstill not best guard we'll see if the
show ends up sticking to that
nando knocks the jet pack to send cop
flying just like han solo did
this same freaking jet pack
malfunctioning is the reason
django was unable to evade mace windu's
swipe
cobb was right this thing is destined to
be busted and you tell your people i
wasn't the one that broke that
now they foreshadow the way they end up
blowing up the beast
hey what are you doing that's an
explosive what are you trying to blow
the whole place up
an homage to jaws which blows up that
beast the same exact way
and foreshadowed it the same exact way
damn it mark just screw around with
these tanks and they're gonna blow up
the tusken raiders retrieve a crate
pearl
this is a super valuable item in the
star wars universe mentioned in the
expanded universe novels like han solo
used to divide into a game of sabac
these are formed by the dragon ingesting
rocks which it's gonna do if it's
children's it's way through sand it's
kind of like how grains of sand can turn
into pearls and clams the final image
shows the famous tatooine binary sunset
and
boba fett to more morrison notice how
his skin is a bit scarred perhaps from
escaping that sarlacc
and you can hear some spurs when he
steps
suggesting he could be the one who came
across fenix shand last season
but most importantly notice that he is
carrying a tuscan rifle
and a tuscan gaffy stick i think boba
fett
could be living among the tuscan raiders
masked along with the rest of them
he could have been that standoff as
tuscan raider back at the campfire
time i'm just saying this would explain
why he doesn't have his armor anymore
maybe he gave it up and no longer serves
him and he might not be that interested
in hunting it back down
but he still could be the key to amanda
learning more about kamino the jedi the
whole star wars history we all know
pretty well
amanda and baby yoda are still strangers
too oh and yes i am wearing uh new rock
stars custom this
is the way shirt available exclusively
at new rockstar's new merch store but
there is a limited number i think we are
running out but when you buy it for a
few bucks more you can write in a custom
shout out that we will include in wookie
leaks episodes so get on this subscribe
to new rockstars hit that notification
bell follow me at ea boss thank you for
watching or as they say in tuscany
[Music]
you